6 15 on your tuesday morning when it
comes to dangerous intersections what's
a way of life for some
may be an eye-opener for others you know
in part one of our five-part series we
checked out one scene of fatal and
serious injury car pedestrian crashes
drivers often going too fast that was
charleston and rainbow
we're not too far from there right now
at sahara and decatur
the number of lanes here and the total
number of vehicles using this
intersection every day has led to a lot
of crashes involving people
running to catch a bus aaron breen and
what i always say to drivers
is treat every
city bus like it's a school bus and i
hope you have respect for a school bus
because
there might be someone that's going to
do something that is going to ruin your
day at the very least
and maybe take their life and
they're not thinking i'm going to lose
my life as they're running for that bus
they're thinking i'm going to lose my
job
if i don't catch that bus
and
kind of makes you stop and think donna i
mean we're all guilty of being wrapped
up in our own worlds whether we're
behind the wheel or on foot we all need
to be responsible for our actions yet
another reminder that all together now
while some intersections are more
dangerous than others any intersection
can be dangerous tomorrow aaron breen's
trifecta of doom intersection can you
imagine what that is
i don't know but i hope it gets
incorporated into your traffic reports
every morning now the trifecta of doom
well it's it's not a good intersection
i'll tell you that and we'll talk about
that tomorrow